hey this is Pete peppers and this is a
level 1 15 candy crush saga saga
walkthrough in explaining the strategy a
little bit was getting ready to run
right my guide and wanted to complete
the level so you could see how it go
sabi got a likes little color and candy
match there so we used our stripes to
get to the rap communities which we need
to do early on as fast as possible
really but when I set them off I made it
so that the coloring candy wouldn't get
hit at that time does that one have done
any good because everything we need is
behind the behind the ice at that time
so it would have done just about nothing
so what I want to do now is um match the
well I'll go ahead and get this color
bomb too but I want to match the fish
with this because now it's opened up and
when we match the fish with the coloring
candy it's going to give us a lot of
fish that are going to go down there and
do a lot of damage so you can see we
need a lot of progress already and the
cell 31 moves left so be nice to make a
fish to go along with this color ball or
this color pump so that worked out
pretty well and this some that's going
to hit that coloring candy but it also
got things move in and took out some of
this middle and now I everything you
know now all the pieces can drop a give
those top row is blocked you know
looking it can cause a problem because
new pieces don't fall in for you alright
so now we're in a pretty good spot here
I think I want to make a fish even
though I can make a rut a raft because
like I said this will go after these
blocks and you don't have a lot of ice
that's all the ice is blocking something
that we want to get three so Fisher are
really good at that
and we can we can take out one of these
or two of these with matches I guess we
also want to look up here for any
specials we can make because even though
we have 24 minutes left so that's pretty
good but it's really hard I'm sure you
know if you played this level it's
really hard to kind of make matches to
get rid of all the ice at the bottom so
at this point in the game we have plenty
of moves left and just by making fish
you know we can we can pretty likely
finish it off I think matching this blue
here is a good idea just to get that out
of the way and so now we get four pieces
of ice so all we need is like the four
individual fish or you know make two
fish and match them together or fish
with a striped candy would be good too
because it will take out two pieces at
the same time if it's a horizontal
stripe like this one so it's little
things like that you know like where you
make that extra fish that are going to
help you get through I mean a lot of
times you might not have as many moves
left as i have here but you know button
by doing that we just save more and now
we finished with 15 you know if you had
three or four moves left that could be a
big that could be make a big difference
so that's pretty much it um like I said
I'm right not the guide now you know you
basically just want to go after try to
get the wrapped candies out as fast as
you can and from there you know just go
ahead and set them off but always check
at the top for you know bomb matches
that you can make so that you can get a
nice combo to clear that space out at
the bottom quickly so I hope it helps
please like the videos we found it
helpful subscribe to our channel so that
you can get the latest videos like this
when they come out
I've good